-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now we're
gonna get to the news.
After Politico
reported on a draft
that a Supreme Court
majority opinion
that overturned Roe vs. Wade,
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeted yesterday that it was
"The most significant and
glorious news of our lifetime."
Now, I'm not a legal scholar,
but I do know this --
if you made that lady happy,
you did something very bad.
President Biden
released a statement today
about the leaked
Supreme Court opinion
and said that if abortion rights
are rolled back,
voters will have to elect
more pro-choice officials
in the midterms.
Okay, you got to stop
putting this on the voters.
You're the president with
control of the House and Senate.
We did the voting thing.
That's like me blaming
a bad show on an intern.
Does it feel good in the moment?
Yeah!
It feels great,
but, at the end of the day,
we all know whose fault it
really is -- Wally's.
Health officials
announced yesterday
that the coronavirus infections
in New York City
have reached
a medium-risk threat level,
which means you have to go from
not wearing a mask
to wearing it below your nose.
According to
unconfirmed reports,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is set to
undergo cancer surgery.
Doctors think that
with their sharpest skills
and a little luck,
they can remove all the Putin.
According to a new study,
a dog's personality has
nothing to do with its breed.
For example, a different collie
pushed Timmy into the well.
The series "Grey's Anatomy"
yesterday celebrated
filming its 400th episode.
That show has been on so long,
all the doctors
are patients now.
A house in Dayton, Ohio, that
has been decorated to look like
Monica's apartment from
the sitcom "Friends"
is currently up for sale
for $162,000,
which is also what
the monthly rent would be
for Monica's apartment
in Manhattan.
And, finally,
the luxury gym Equinox
will reportedly begin
accepting cryptocurrency
as a form of
payment this summer,
while Planet Fitness will begin
accepting Marlboro Miles.
And that was
the monologue, everybody!